[Music]
I got the role of Mike Barnes from an
open call there were like 2 000 people
standing in line to audition for John
Albertson who had directed the first
karate kid from the second won the Oscar
for Rocky he picked me out of the line
what's your name
and sag so when I went in to the uh The
Sound Stage to go uh screen test with
Ralph Macchio there were a lot of
different media Outlets there and I
vividly remember doing an interview for
entertainment tonight and I was like I
was this kid from Pennsylvania and I was
like just didn't interview for
Entertainment Tonight that's insane we
are gonna find that that's what scares
me I've studied karate for about five
years and I've been in La for about a
year and a half acting it's been going
pretty well and funny thing is my head
instructor did all the choreography for
Karate Kid one and two you modemera and
uh since I moved out here this is
something I've wanted to give a try so
I'm really excited to be here you want a
little demonstration of what I can do
yeah
um yeah just a couple kicks or something
sure
as you're rolling back into repricing
your role over on COBRA coffee
well you must be Mike Barnes welcome to
L.A what can you tell me what was the
experience like we're all so excited you
know it was amazing to go back to uh
reprise this role it's a role I did 35
years ago you know as an actor you don't
think that you're gonna reprise a role
you did that long ago let alone that
it's going to have some relevance and
that the fans are still interested in it
it was amazing to go back down there you
know Ralph and I were working together
and we just were looking at each other
going can you believe this and the thing
I love about Ralph and Billy they're
terrific guys and it was great to go
back there and reignite our friendship
as adults rather than you know 35 years
ago but they're so in awe of what has
happened and the Juggernaut that uh
Cobra Kai has become and it's just nice
to see that they're not jaded you know
they're really enjoying the ride and for
me it was just so much fun to go
proverbial proverbially dust off the
black sleeveless ski and uh and mix it
up legendary
all right Sean I'm gonna let you get out
of here anything else anything else you
want to say brother uh gosh I think the
only thing I would want to say man is
that your karate is a joke
oh all right my karate is a choke what
do you know
[Music]
foreign